let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] them
[Music]
well hello
all of you out there
[Music]
in the interwebs
listening to this great let's talk the
tony michaels podcast today
today we have a special guest
on our podcast
he is someone who has met the former
vice president of the united states mike
pence
he's gonna give us a couple stories
about
the former vice president mike pence
because i have a lot of questions
about
january 6 where mike pence was where he
wasn't
who he was on the phone with does he
know who jeffrey rosen is
maybe maybe trump doesn't even know who
this mike pence character is maybe he's
just a coffee boy at this point i don't
know i don't know what we're gonna ask
we're gonna ask our guests today though
about some stories that he has
about the former vice president and the
former governor of indiana
mike pence so we're going to do that
today with our guests we're also we're
also going to get into a little bit
about trump going to prison is he going
is he not going
will he go
where will he go
would be a a county jail will it be a
state prison what about a federal prison
i don't know maybe a nice luxury condo
in russia so we're going to talk about
that as well
today but i want to bring my guest on my
guest
is the executive producer of the noel
castler podcast jimmy kennedy and he's
also the host of his own podcast the jbk
on air
and that's where you can find him on
twitter instagram is jbk on there that's
his handle
that's where you need to find him at or
just search jimmy kennedy and you'll
you'll find him
but he's the executive producer of the
no castler podcast which is taken off
no castler does his car rants
he does the podcast
everyone needs to listen to this podcast
and you need to go listen to jimmy's
podcast as well i'm going to bring him
in here
jimmy how you doing buddy hey tony tony
tony thanks for having me on yeah yeah
yeah so so tell me a little bit about
the podcast you're the executive
producer right uh on on noel's podcast
and then you have your own podcast so
tell us about the difference in the
content is there a difference what what
is the what is the goal of these
podcasts what kind of content is this
mine jbk on air is kind of just a
creative vessel for my content that when
i'm feeling creative i'll put it on
there um several of the people that i've
talked to are media professionals so if
you're interested in
doing something in media and want some
mentorship on how to get started i
talked to a lot of my friends that i've
met in the past that are my age and
people that i've uh
admired in the business uh and then the
noel castler podcast is one that i
worked with uh with noel casler he's a
stand-up comedian based out of new york
city
and that primarily is going to be
talking about politics and just current
events going on in the week
a lot of his background is in live music
as well as live television so
anything in pop culture can kind of be
covered on our show but for right now
a lot of the talk is about
trump and the
chaos agent that he is to our republic
so
so so noel
and i i have been watching and noel has
a great insight on trump and even people
surrounding trump because he's worked a
lot in the business
um and it's it's crazy the amount of
stories
that he has about some of these people
uh behind the scenes now obviously
there's some pressure uh on some of
these stories that he's actually been
telling i'm sure
is that is that is that fair to say
that
i noticed i noticed the other day that
his twitter account got hacked
well he's certainly speaking truth to
power um and i you know i'm not i'm not
as good of a storyteller especially when
it's not my perspective to tell so i i'm
gonna tease it to send people to the
podcast because that's good that's good
well that's well tells the story is a
lot better than me but um that's what an
executive producer is supposed to do
right yeah so listen listen to no tell
the stories but one guy i could give you
a reference point with is mike pence
yeah you know former vp and governor uh
of the same indiana the first time that
i met him uh face-to-face was at a colts
game that was my background and how i
met noel uh during the trump regime and
hit and it being just terrible
i reached out to him because i had heard
him heard him in an interview and i said
hey you know let me let me talk to you
and let me ask you some questions
because i wanted to see what i could
gather from noel's perspective and um
going back to mike pence
i had been um a game day staff member
for the indianapolis colts for four
seasons and it was very similar to the
job that knoll did in entertainment
where i was essentially a go-between i
was a liaison
for the public relations department with
the indianapolis colts and there's a
area on the field at lucas oil where if
you're in the media and you need b-roll
for
the nightly news or if you're going to
be espn and covering the game you'll be
in that area i was the first guy you
would talk to at lucas oil when you walk
on the area of the field
and
when i met uh former vp uh mike pence he
was still governor at that point he
hadn't been chosen by trump as the vp
um he walked out onto the field saw me
and keep in mind i'm i'm the only guy
visible within you know 100 yards of the
actual field
and
he says uh you know how are you you know
shakes my hand and
it kind of seemed like a photo op
opportunity you know because i'm i'm a
person with disability
um but it wasn't like a make a wish
situation you know i was a staff member
for the colts i had a tie on you know so
for me it seemed a little
put on the whole facade of him coming up
to me
um just because
i think he's a little opportunistic like
that you know if he gets
a picture or some video of him talking
to a kid with a walker it's gonna help
him in the polls the next week so i'm
not saying that's his intention i don't
know where his heart lies but
it seemed awfully opportunistic uh when
he met me on the field that day
wow yeah
who would wouldn't anyone imagine that
mike pence would take an opportunity
to to advance his political career right
well one other thing i want to say
having a disability i can tell when
somebody's talking to me as a person
or as you know hey buddy aren't you glad
to be here you know isn't this a great
game it was more that for mike you know
like
it's so good to see you good for you
standing here you know like oh
you know it felt that way now i have
reservations about mike but again
right you know he works with trump he's
gonna take every opportunity he can to
advance himself even if it's at my
expense the
the uh the thing is
regardless of his intention
uh the problem is for mike pence is
we totally can we totally can imagine
that his intention
uh would be ill-gotten in that situation
and uh it's so it felt that gross when
he kind of
hey well
you guys like patting you on the head or
what is it
well
it was like
and as he was walking away i'm like
oh that's that's it you know i mean
there was there wasn't a lot to mike i
thought he would be you know more of a
powerful presence
um well you know but um
and the funny thing too tony he's like
20 minutes from me uh you know i'm i'm
living in the suburb that he's at now
right right oh oh so you're talking
about you're now 20 minutes from where
he bought a house and then living now so
the mansion that he bought in this in a
suburb of indianapolis where i'm at
it's a multi-million dollar home i've
seen it you can find the zillow link
and um
you know it's about 20 minutes outside
of a golf course that's hosted the pga
championship uh john daly won back in
the 90s at this course right hosted the
bmw championship a few years ago
um
you know so it's a it's a wealthy area
and he's got the money because he signed
a a book deal with simon schuster a
while back and it's going to well they
all get a book deal that's the purpose
of trump man that's right man that's the
whole purpose i said this uh on
wednesday on the last podcast about bill
barr the reason why bill barth told
trump now no not gonna do that whole
federal crime thing uh is because he
wants a book deal you know bill barr and
i think bill barr got his book deal too
didn't he i think that that news dropped
it's in the making if it's not why yeah
he's gonna get one well uh and i got one
more story so oh oh show another mike
pence story this is another mike pence
story so uh before i don't know exactly
the
the measure of events because i you
gotta remember i'm born in 1994 i'm only
26 years old so it's hard for me to
recount this information so between the
time that he was in congress uh and the
time that he was governor he was shortly
a talk show host in indianapolis on wibc
which is our conservative you know news
talk station
and my one of my teachers
i graduated from the university of
indianapolis
before working for the university he
worked for the network that carried mike
pence's show
and he said that mike pence was similar
to rush limbaugh but worse you know he
would just read the newspaper and quote
the bible you know as information
over over the airwaves
and one day you know and for anybody
that's been in radio they'll understand
this you know you have the talk you have
the host and the talk room and then you
have the producer with the board and all
the buttons right
the one of the cardinal rules in radio
is that if you're a producer you never
leave the studio without at least
letting the host know because more often
than not the host doesn't have a radio
background to get you on off the air
so um
but one day
mike's producer just walked out like
he said screw it you know i'm done and
had enough of the bible verses i guess
and at that point it was a syndicated
show like the the producer ended up
getting fired but you know mike had
behaved so poorly that it caused his
producer to say okay you know i don't
want to take this anymore you know like
that's that's the kind of personality uh
that he has i guess when it comes to
forming a working relationship you know
well the i i think i think that's that's
actually
something that a lot of people
don't know about mike pence's because if
you go back and you listen to some of
his radio clips or even when he would
give speeches on the floor when he was a
member of congress uh even when he was
the governor of indiana he was a
completely different person than when he
was vice president
his transformation into
what he who he was when he was vice
president was to basically
go hey don't worry about the buffoon
there's someone here who has a brain and
who can operate and function as a
political figure
you know
and do this policy thing
it really did seem like that like mike
pence was never really this uh
at least this is my impression
from all the media that i've seen of
mike pence prior to
uh his his his
his
acceptance as the cheeto dust knee pad
for trump was he wasn't this soft-spoken
measured guy
he was a flamethrower and that was his
intent and and and then he he changed
what he was when he became the candidate
for when he when he got on the ticket
for trump well
i don't necessarily agree with that
he's a guy that loves power you know and
loves the prestige of power you're
saying that republicans only care about
power come on well well i mean you have
to realize too you know he's a guy that
pushed for
um
the really the religious freedom
restoration act you know referral which
was the whole
i think it turned into a supreme court
case where it was like
a bakery can refuse to make a cake for a
gay couple you know that whole thing
right and it's like
a private business doesn't have to
necessarily serve someone you know if
they don't choose to now certainly you
have different parameters that you could
be sued for but it wasn't necessary it
wasn't an issue but they made it
political because and they tied religion
to it you know we've always talked about
the separation of church and state it
seems to be getting closer and closer
and let me tell you mike pence is the
handmaid's tale version of trump if if
we had
if we had him and mother right him and
mother right exactly
he can't even be in the room without
with another woman if mother's not there
god i wish i would have i wish i would
have pulled a tick tock that i have
about him uh uh on january 6
about uh him being in a room uh he
couldn't be in a room with a woman it uh
that that to me
i mean
how does it speak to your character when
you say well
i can't be in a room with another woman
like is it that you can't trust the
woman or you can't trust yourself
because it really does it really does
feel like you can't
trust yourself and your wife can't try i
don't know i don't know i just it's a
weird power dynamic for sure and the
weird thing too about the whole
you know uniting of pence and trump
trump needed somebody to get the
evangelical vote you know but and who is
less christian than donald trump
seriously you know i mean i mean there
is there is a small list right and most
of them most of them look like mike
pence but you know
you know that
you know i'm saying
the package of both trump and mike pence
uh
was showcased very beautifully amongst
the heartland you know it tru uh noel
always talks about how they how they
thought the bible flags and guns you
know if they hit those main three
you're gonna get
of the vote you know or whatever the
percentage is of the the base guns god
and country that's right guns god and
country well i mean we we grew up in the
midwest you're from indiana i'm from
missouri so i mean we grew up in these
in these places where this is this is
the the shtick right
it's it's it's the old
the old red white and blue shtick where
you know you have to have a certain
certain perspective
or
or carry a certain book
uh to
or quote from a certain book like a mike
pence or marco rubio
that
when you said that earlier about mike
pence spouting off bible verses it
reminds me of marco rubio's twitter
account he just like he's just like hey
i'm a christian bible verse hey i'm a
christian bible verse like dude we we
get it we get it
we get it like we can read too it's i
don't know but anyways this back to this
whole gods gun country
um so what you're saying is you think
the reason why jared and ivanka wanted
him to pick mike pence is because they
thought mike pence could deliver a
victory because i remember
i remember when he was picking mike
pence they like held him over on the
plane
and they really they really had to work
to get trump to pick pence
because pence is kind of the anti-trump
kind of look right i mean it
he's he's not you're not gonna be able
to accuse mike pence of having sex with
a porn star why his wife is pregnant
with his with his eighth child right
exactly you're just that's not the kind
of guy mike pence is he doesn't even go
in a room with another woman let alone
be within 100 feet of a porn star so
what you're saying is is they picked him
to be the
the maybe the mirror image of trump so
they could sell the gods gun country
thing
and i guess
you need you need a face to appease the
evangelicals the uh the westboro baptist
church
uh
you know group amongst your followers
you know the the bible thumper the guy
that will
you know put on the the sourpuss face
and the usual
uh you know thoughts and prayers
rhetoric that we've heard from
republicans last 20 years without any
real action and
you know i'm also a guy that's aware
that you know
when you compare the a scale of
uh from conservative to liberal it's not
like joe biden has been
liberal uh in comparison to other folks
for a majority of his career so i've
also been critic critical of joe biden
because when you go as far right as we
went with trump
you kind of have to go that far left to
balance it out and at this point it's
still business as usual and
we don't have the team that we need to
go up against the forces that we're
going up against right now
so you make a good point there as far as
the body politics because i think that's
a good discussion that we're gonna have
to have uh once all this trump
administration criming and stuff starts
to wind down
of what's going to happen with that
because we're going to talk about that
here in a minute too with rosen and uh
you know if trump going to prison but i
think the body politic is super
important because the problem that we
have with the right wing is there's no
one interested in policy like nope they
have no no platform
at all like it is they are their party
their fascists well well right well i
mean absolutely but but they're but
their party is dead they have no i was
talking
uh to my wife the other day about this
is that
i said challenge me tell me one thing
that they're for
that they're for and she said well guns
and i said now they're against gun
control
you know it's their their their focus is
not for guns it's it's against gun
control right yeah that's well that's
their aim their aim isn't for guns their
aim is against gun control they spend
gazillions of corporate money
to stop
sensible gun
laws
that's their that's their force behind
their their you know
their shiv that's what they're trying to
do and then she said abortion and i are
pro-life and i said oh good lord
pro-life
pro-life give me a break their their
anti-health care how can they be
pro-life
did you see did you see the video of
rand paul
this this this vaccinated [ __ ]
goes on goes on the internet and tells
people resist
do not comply with the vaccine and i'm
like dude you people you people have got
this liberty and freedom thing so
[ __ ] twisted in your minds
you people do not have the right it's
not a constitutional right to get on an
airplane that's not a thing that is not
a thing
it's not written in the constitution ye
must ye must be allowed to get on
airplane if it's not in there you won't
find it that's not a [ __ ] thing
it doesn't say that you you are
guaranteed a job
rather you're vaccinated or not that
doesn't that you don't have that
constitutional right that's not a thing
literally when you said fascism that is
that is the
the root cause but these people don't
even know that's what it is
they have no clue dude they're so
twisted around with this q anon stuff
but here's the thing dude they don't
care and that's the bigger issue when it
comes to america we're over stimulated
we're over entertained you know there
was a reason why superhero movies came
out every month a few years ago because
we're looking for a savior to save us
from what i think is a broken system in
capitalism which will ultimately lead to
more issues with global warming you know
like
i'm not trying to overthrow the
government i'm saying the systems within
our government aren't working anymore
and we can change them nobody says that
we have to be a capitalist country we're
choosing to make that
choice because
it's a lot easier to control people in a
capitalist society you know you have a
ceo that makes millions of dollars and
then can fire you know thousands of
workers
is that really fair in the end
you know i don't know
and it's not like i'm some kind of
economic professor but whatever's going
on isn't working whatever you call this
whatever's currently going on
ain't working so let's try something
different i can i completely agree now i
i will i will say
that my my stance is is that
it it's not capitalism that is the root
of the problem it's the corporate
fascism that is the root of the problem
sure um because capitalism at one point
in this country ceos didn't make the
exorbitant amount of money that they
make uh versus their
low-lying employees you know the the
low-level entry employees they didn't
there was not the disparity at points in
our country now there's a lot of social
economical uh history there to to unpack
all that
but i believe
i believe that this uh plutocracy this
uh corporate fascism is really is really
the root for the problem and the problem
is and and you said it just a minute ago
you have
very few ceos versus
all
the other workforce right and i think
that's what's kind of going on in our
body politics like we were talking
earlier is
that
you have a
minority party
ruling over a huge swath
of people
uh for instance the senate or 50 50. but
dude the disparity in votes for the
amount of votes for those 50 democrats
versus those 50 republicans is
absolutely
ridiculous as far as we can't get
uh uh a
voting rights bill
they're having trouble with this
infrastructure bill now it looks like
they're gonna get the infrastructure
bill um but they
think we can't even agree on what the
[ __ ] word infrastructure means
anymore
well who's against infrastructure who
seriously gets that i mean that that's
my issue you know uh
and i'll tell you why there's nothing
going on in the senate because
everybody's bought on both sides
including joe manchin from west virginia
you know he's on the energy committee
there's a reason why
they're able to dump chemicals with
impunity in west virginia because a guy
like joe manchin is gonna
go toward his interest as opposed to the
interests of the people you know and
that and that's my issue with
republicans too you allow these
uh companies like exxon and mobile to um
you know
pollute with impunity
but then you don't pay for
the cancer treatment that's gonna
uh
be widespread because of all the stuff
that gets sent into our waterways you
know like you have to pay for one or the
other or you're just completely leading
to a society without humanity you know
it's we've drifted so far tony in the
last
40 years since reagan that um
there's not a lot of humanity left in
people anymore they've lost touch with a
lot of it hey hey hey don't don't bring
reagan into this
yeah the the hero right you know what's
crazy you know what's crazy is you would
turn on uh fox news or any kind of
conservative talk and i mean every five
minutes they would say the name reagan
they they have worked so far away from
even reagan that they don't even know
what ronald who
who's this ronald what what's this
trickle down what's this stuff i don't
we i don't even know what do you mean
we're supposed to be against taxes or
against deficits
what
what is this stuff
they they drifted so far and that's what
we were talking about earlier is that
they don't have a policy
they don't they don't have anything
they're for like nothing i mean other
than one thing and that's you know the
cheeto dust mobster that's the one thing
they are for is the cheeto dust mobster
they could that's the only thing they
can figure out
to be for and i and i believe i believe
that it is a beautiful thing
uh in this country to watch them
self-destruct because i think that's
what's happening is is this this big
divide that we have in the country uh
we've had this divide for a long time
it's it's the minority rule forcing the
majority to not have a government that
they want right we're in it we're in a
democratic republic where the majority
can create the government that they want
with the constitution that we have
because it's a living document that's
why they hate the constitution
and then they pretend to like the
constitution by saying oh well it's you
know
they they take up
the founders the founders the founders
the founders were [ __ ] slave owners
exactly they didn't they wouldn't half
the
people who vote for trump wouldn't have
been allowed to vote back then anyways
it was for rich white landowning males
okay
stop with the founders they're dead
they're gone okay
they're unintended consequence of their
document to make sure that we had
liberty
we get to take advantage of that but it
is it is sort of an unintended
consequence let's be let's be fair about
that but
uh i don't even know i'm just on a rant
here but yeah but back to back to
the the workforce and the minority
majority rule i think that's the divide
in the country but their party really is
already dead like it's dead but the
problem is is they have power everywhere
they have power everywhere but they
don't know what to do with it that's why
they're like audit in arizona
and
and
bamboo in the ballots and watermarks
like they can't even they have no
direction on
what can actually make them move forward
i mean do you think do you think this
garbage is a good way forward for the
republican party at all
well
they're beyond they're at a point of no
return they can't go back to the the
days of traditional gop politics um you
know they're what they're doing right
now tony is they're buying time either
for iran desantis
you know who i think will bring the
whole thing down you want to see the
republic go away nominate a ron desantis
and see
how crazy [ __ ] gets um
you know
you're saying he's crazier than trump
i'm saying he's smarter and smoother
than trump
you know like trump wasn't to our
benefit trump was an idiot like he said
out loud that he was
hoping to investigate china for election
fraud you know like his crimes were in
plain sight and said
with
enthusiasm you know uh desantis has all
the mannerisms and but the guy went to
harvard you know he's not an idiot even
if you sat in the back of a class at
harvard you're going to be smarter than
a guy that went to then went to
community college you know you're
surrounded by smart people it's not like
these guys don't know what they're doing
they're about controlling people and
what's sad is
all these folks who are you know
evangelicals these gun owners these uh
folks that need a ford f-150
you know they're all trying to
create this john wayne
kind of uh identity for themselves and
it's [ __ ] it's it's
it's killing the planet and it will
ultimately unravel the society you know
everything that was kind of put in place
by reagan um
is kind of taking
uh coming home to roost now and um the
only thing that
reagan did that is still benefiting us
is dr fauci but you know they've they've
already kind of cut ties with them
well i mean they had to have someone to
blame
you cannot you can't blame the cheeto
dust mobster that it just he's
infallible right and back to desantis
because i i'd like to touch on that
before we get to
uh this rosen thing and this trump going
to prison um sure but but the uh the ron
desantis does a horrible trump
impression it's
really bad it's it's i mean i know
that's what he's trying to do but it's
it's it's not it's not on at all he
doesn't have the voice down he doesn't
have the cadence down he's got the hand
gestures down he's got the oversized
shitty fitted suit on
kind of changed his hair a bit he really
needs to diet a little bit but what
you're saying what you're saying is
because ron desantis knows how
government works right he is the
ultimate danger not him
probably specific josh josh holly would
be in equal danger guys like that that
were
they were on the fast track to be a
senator anyway you know like josh hawley
taught at st paul's as soft of a place
as you can go you know and i and i and i
live in a place uh that's
that had one of the top lacrosse
programs in the country my high school
okay that's all you need to know about
my high school and the kind of folks
that went there okay right um so i know
these guys i know how they
want to carry themselves and project
themselves to the populace but they're
they're full of [ __ ] they're all
so you've met you've met a handful of
josh hawley's before 100 i have yeah you
know what's crazy because josh hawley is
the senator of my great state of
missouri
and he is he is a he is a
a complete and utter fraud i can't i
can't even imagine how anyone in
missouri is like yeah that's a good
representation a guy who uses his
sister's address
in in in the the general area of
springville missouri
and owns a house in virginia doesn't
even own a property in missouri owns no
property in missouri is is the missouri
the senator from missouri doesn't even
live here
how they think that's a good
representation their state i have no
idea and really i said this this morning
on twitter because josh ali is trending
because of the infrastructure bill but
you know you know the famous picture
where he's pumping his fist you know i i
i said on twitter this morning he really
needs to straighten his arm out and get
his [ __ ] fingers up there you know
really get that that proper salute adolf
would be highly disappointed
he can hold up
hey speaking of trump card
uh uh so you've seen the trump card
thing i have seen it i'm thinking about
getting one in case the gestapo stapes
drops by my house i can say i'm a card
carrying member boys i'm good
so so which one do you want do you want
the ones with the misspellings or with
the with the nazi eagle on it which one
are you going for i'll have both in case
you know they they want to right you
gotta have options you know you turn it
around flip it around you might have
both the miss smelling might actually be
worth more that you know so
you know what you know what we're in for
here with this this trump card thing is
uh i'm just waiting i'm waiting on to
hear the story or even the viral video
of someone not being able to get into a
restaurant of a trump bumper somewhere
who owns a restaurant because they don't
have their trump card and there's this
this thing that ensues their their their
trump passport as it were you know
because they're so against passports but
they're for their i know they'll be for
the trump passport it's got the gold
eagle well yeah yeah it's you know
yeah the nazi eagle what is wrong with
them
do they really is it really does it does
the irony just not even
how does it not compute man or the
scarier thing is they know what's going
on and i think that's the problem yeah
they see it that's what the intention
was that's what the intention was dude
trump would recite mind conf he read
that stuff he read that stuff when you
have stephen miller when you have
stephen miller and they're standing at
the desk advising you stephen miller
that
get goblin nazi yeah you're gonna you're
gonna bannon a nationalist you're gonna
have that stuff leaked through so let's
talk about real quick about the uh real
quick let's talk about the jeffrey rosen
thing uh because this is big news uh i i
think this is really
uh the
find out
stage of the [ __ ] around saga right
right um where jeffrey rosen not only
did he go to the department of justice
uh ig and tell and spill his guts on
what trump and jeffrey clarke were up to
but apparently yesterday uh
jeffrey rosen
testified in front of the senate
judiciary committee for seven hours
seven hours he testified in front of the
judiciary committee
and i know it is not just about one
goddamn letter
uh from that jeffrey clark drafted
there's got to be much more that he was
testifying against for seven hours of
testimony now
senator blumenthal who was at that uh
that that testimony
and witnessed the majority of the
testimony said yesterday that
there is uh a ton of stuff that jeffrey
rosen had basically receipts that they
had given the judiciary committee
uh basically
to lock trump up there's criminal
liability there for trump but
you're saying and we were talking about
this earlier before we came on air
you're saying
that you don't think
trump will actually pay a price
well i mean define pay a price you know
like the guy is 75 years old 74 75 years
old he's
he's done basically what he's wanted to
do his entire life and we're going to
hold him to account now and
look man i hate to say it folks the
world works in a way that rich white men
don't go to prison and if they do go to
prison it's the country club of prisons
you know we saw aunt becky a couple
years ago
she put her daughter
through college and screwed several kids
out of a opportunity and ended up you
know going to prison for like two weeks
you know like
nothing happens to these folks and
joe biden
he's kicking ass you know don't send me
dms that i hate joe biden i don't i
think he's doing great you know we've
maintained the republic but he's also
part of the old guard he knows how this
world works
and i don't think you know merrick
garland the same deal um
even if his specialty is domestic
terrorism you know they got rid of
timothy mcveigh in the state of indiana
quicker than
uh you know any kind of responsibility
for
trump that um
with everything that's happened you know
so
it's disappointing um but i just don't
think you're gonna put a guy with that
much uh
prestige behind
behind bars i don't see it happening
so let me try to convince you because
i i actually do believe that uh trump
will be
held some somewhat accountable yes one
other thing i'll say he's in florida
right governor desantis will have a
standoff before they actually try and
arrest him so you're you're saying the
the the celebrity and impersonator will
protect him is that what you're saying
yeah i'm saying that
he's the system is designed to protect
him and he's leveraged it as president
of the united states to ensure that it's
that he's fine yeah so so i have talked
about it here on this podcast and i talk
about it
uh
in my videos as in some of my tic tacs
the ticky tacks that i do
um i i actually think uh donald trump
will pay a price here here's here's why
i think that this is
going in areas that donald trump does
not want it to go and why he releases
some of these crazy statements that he
does
because he can't tweet so he's got to do
whatever that is that he does he he puts
a statement out and then he has his
minions tweet images of it uh which no
one pays attention to no one even
watched his
uh read his blog he did a blog thing for
like three weeks and then uh
the getter the the the the social app
whatever the hell he's got we get her
done or get her or grab her by the way i
don't know
that that didn't go well
but
i believe
i believe that there's several
components here that are going to really
put trump in a prison corner and the
reason why i say this is there's several
different investigations going on and
there's several people already indicted
in these investigations number one you
have the manhattan d.a who has his tax
returns that grand jury has his tax
returns
and they actually have indicted uh alan
weisselberg which there is no clear
signal that alan weiselberg is
cooperating in that case
but alan weisselberg actually ties to
another federal investigation
or another person in the federal
investigation that has been indicted his
name is tom barrack tom barrack is also
a a trump stooge
and those two tom barrick and alan
weiselberg show up in the inaugural
committee that's where they show up
together now to be fair to be fair to
both of these people neither of these
charges have anything to do with the
inaugural committee now i believe that
is planned here that is planned
and the reason why i think it's planned
is because we've heard roger stone over
and over and over on social media
basically
land blasting ivanka trump and jared
kushner because i think i think
someone's cooperating here because
ivanka shows up
ivanka shows up on the inaugural
committee as well
so alan weiselberg ivanka trump
and tom barrack all show up on this
inaugural committee because the question
is
not only where did the money go because
there's money that no one's like where
the hell did this money go it went in
trump's pocket that's where it went it
went in a [ __ ] pocket but everyone's
wondering where the money went but the
real question is not really where the
money might everyone knows where the
[ __ ] it went
the question is
they have to prove that but the question
really is
where did the money come from
where did the money come from and the
funny part is tom barrack's indictment
has to do
with the saudis basically
and the very first trip that trump made
the very first one
was where where did he go jimmy do you
remember i'm trying
oh
that's right that's right that's right
so so this is all kind of it's just it's
just convenient that this that this
quilt of inaugural committee is
happening under under these guys of
criminal activity
and you have jared kushner's uh triple
six avenue building you know being
funded by
uh i believe it's uh banks in uae you
know so all of it's interconnected and
as far as the inaugural stuff
uh related trump uh noel talks about
this but he was at both of barack
obama's inaugurations okay and they had
everyone uh performing at this uh thing
they did like a three-hour broadcast on
hbo
um they had sting
stevie wonder uh john legend
name any performer you're talking about
a lot of money you're talking about a
lot of money a lot of heavy hitters that
you're gonna have to pay a heavy price
for all of it together was 40 to 50
million dollars you know so
whatev
you know trump got a substantial amount
of money from
what was from what went down through
that whole thing and you know it was the
beginning of a four year long grift that
he's continued at this point
um the last i checked it was like 75
million dollars in his pack you know he
has a war chest that he's going to use
in this next election cycle and he's
gonna and the thing is he's a king maker
too tony you know anybody that he
endorses or says you know don't vote for
this guy
it either makes or breaks them that's
the other thing well we did see in the
texas six district uh several weeks ago
we did see
that he floundered on a race um he did
lose he did lose an endorsement race
down there in the sixth district of
texas so i
i think he's more irrelevant because i
think the actual biggest fraud that
there is the biggest fraud that he's
ever brought on our country
is that he actually has
all these people out there supporting
him i think it's kind of [ __ ] i mean
i think he has a base i think he has a
large swath of people it is a large
number of people
but him thinking that it's 70 80 million
people that will
that will stand and fight for him and
come on man come on daddy that's all i
don't know man i mean that's all
[ __ ] here's the deal after four
years of hell
like we were on the break of collapse
he's still got 74 million votes and
there's not as disturbing it is
disturbing and you know what joe biden
isn't a fascist but economically there's
not a lot of difference
there's not okay
like
you're saying you're saying the economy
today is not different than it was it's
we're still capitalist
yeah but but but isn't that the same
with every price isn't that all the
[ __ ] line between president the
president no matter who it is
somehow it's different
i'm saying the part of the appeal for
biden was that uh you know moderate
uh republicans would vote for him right
right that's my point
joe biden has been around for 40 years
and maybe that was part of the break
from him you know but still 74 million
people wanted another round of that [ __ ]
after 40 years well i mean total [ __ ]
show i i mean man when you when you're
when you're on when you think that
you're on the good end of fascism
you're for it no i'm dead serious right
right i mean that's
no one
not as many people as as they want to
think cheered hitler on in the beginning
it was only re it was only realized when
when oh
he's not going to come for us where are
you
sure
yeah the crazy thing is dude we saw him
attack the capital how much more do you
need to know but this guy's crazy but
but to be fair to be fair all those
votes were were cast before he attacked
the capital and i think i think that's
what is very important about 2022 and
2024
what i mean is is that we will get
electoral proof of how irrelevant or
relevant he is so
uh we know how many votes he got in
2020 and then uh the big lie all the
[ __ ] everyone knew he lost even
people voted for him jesus christ
he lost too right well i mean that's
where this jeffrey rosen stuff's going
to come in but everyone knew he lost we
got to january 6 the insurrection
happened
and man i i we haven't seen a real
nationwide vote yet uh where where trump
is what you say king maker and gonna
endorse these people and we're gonna see
that in 2022 so we're gonna find out how
many votes there are still for him or
against him and how relevant he is
um
and i think i think this jeffrey rosen
stuff these the select committee i
believe that these federal
investigations we were just talking
about with tom barack barrick uh the
manhattan da's case against alan
weisselberg i even think the case the
federal case down in florida against
joel greenberg
has a lot to do with trump because in
that case there was money being
transferred supposedly to roger stone to
get him a pardon through rudy giuliani
and jared kushner and rudy giuliani
there we go again he's in a lot of
federal trouble and he's begging trump
begging trump to pay attention to me hey
look at me look at me please pay my
bills so i can afford attorneys it's
it's getting it's getting really really
really really really small in that
criminal corner that he's standing in is
all i'm saying now uh i i
i will say that i'm not really sure what
it looks like for a former president to
go to prison like that's the thing
i i think i think we're gonna the
crime's gonna catch up with him but what
i don't know is what it looks like i
mean we've never done this before what
is it if it's a federal prison do we
actually put him in prison do we i mean
what do we do do we let him stay at
mar-a-lago i i i mean that's the thing
that i'm
like what the [ __ ] did how does that
work
or does he get on a plane and go to
russia maybe he bunks with putin i don't
know i mean
i
you know thinking about it in a trump
way what i what i would do is like put
him in a padded cell and then just put
several webcams on and have people pay
you know five bucks a month to watch him
you know just
this as a people watching opportunity
you know so you're saying a grift a
griff even after he's but i'm saying
it's like it's like the best reality
show and he's similar to the riddler or
the joker you know he's kind of a
psychopath of a person where you might
want to watch him be in a padded room
and see what
well i mean
you know
i think i think this president thing was
all accidental anyways i mean don't you
think he would prefer to be known as the
great businessman on tv you know the
fake businessman on tv and be able to
run around acting and you know
pretending to be a billionaire
for the rest of his life rather than
having to stave off all these federal
investigations because he would really
like to still commit crime and stuff you
know now it's really tough to commit
crime when you're you know you got the
eyes watching you but well
as noel says you know and he has
experience firsthand with trump uh on
celebrity apprentice you know he says
that uh when
trump walks into a room he wants music
to play when he walks in he wants to get
high and he wants to grab women you know
he's all about what's going to
immediately satisfy his narcissistic
needs so whatever that is at that time
whether it be a you know a handful of
cash or a stack of uh cheeseburgers and
he's gonna shove down his gullet uh you
know he's going to have it at that time
um
trump trump is a scumbag of a human
being and
and you know what we're we're all guilty
and and nominating him uh and we all
play a part of it part in it even if we
didn't vote for him you know we allowed
for a guy like trump to rise up uh and
that shows we've been dumbed down well
we are we are reality tv based in this
country uh and and you know the the
craziest part is that
our our professional wrestling uh
tendencies no i'm dead serious yeah you
know i i've had this conversation with
uh one of my friends of mine and he
brought it up he said look what is
happening what trump is is he's the real
life steve austin became president of
the united states exactly and and it's
kind he's like it's kind of
disappointing that that it you know
people know that wrestling is fake but
they pretend that it's real right i mean
you wanna you want to pretend that it's
real because that makes it more
entertaining i think what happened was
is a lot of these people who didn't pay
attention to politics who had no clue
how government works they have no clue
how policy works they have no clue how
roads and bridges get built and how all
that's funded they have no idea how
schools are done they don't know but
it's fun and it's fun to
you know root for the bad guy it's fun
to root for
cold stone steve austin bust a beer over
his face and guzzle it right i mean
that's a fun thing to do especially when
it's not real but you can pretend that
it's real i mean professional wrestling
really is the birth of reality tv
everyone thinks it was real on mtv but
it was not it really was professional
wrestling that brought reality tv
uh that that that that genre to this
country well and and trump and vince
mcmahon have been friends for
generations they've been friends for 30
years you know he hosted wrestlemania 3
at trump plaza he's not he's been
familiar with that business for years
right you know right so and
and i as far as my background in
professional wrestling i started a
charity wrestling event you know where
where uh kids with disabilities could
perform as a character and uh get to
showcase their ability as opposed to a
disability so right i've been in the
ring i understand the psychology of the
business a little bit i've been around
folks that have trained
uh you know any kind of wrestler that's
out there today um
they've they've crossed paths with them
or know of them so that's at least where
my knowledge base is well well right but
but don't you think
that uh of certain percentage of the
population
uh took
took their
their attitude towards wrestling and
applied it towards politics 100
yeah i mean i mean they took what they
know about being a fan for professional
wrestling and really projected that on
to
on to trump and i think it was an
accident you know he came down the
escalator he decided to use racism
because that's what he'd been using
against obama for for several years it
was working it was getting him attention
so he decided to use racism when he was
talking about rapists and criminals
coming across the border and i think the
unintended consequence was that there
was this underlying
uh
hate in this country that they were
ready
they were ready for the anti-obama the
the arch enemy of obama to be the
president and to divide the country with
racism and they were like up that's our
that's our heel that's the stone we're
gonna root for the heel we're gonna
print t-shirts and hats we're gonna have
flags and we're gonna you know we're
gonna cheer to the music and he's gonna
he's gonna be our heel and we are gonna
root for the heel and i
you know i i don't know
i'm not a
psychology i've taken some psychology
classes in college but i'm no psychology
major but
i really do believe that a lot of this
is they know that this is all [ __ ]
but it's fun to pretend that it's real
like that like even
they're all making money in the process
too though man yeah i mean that's
that's the other thing you know i mean
uh it's
it's a frustrating thing dude like our
politics was in decline before trump
sarah palin was gonna was
one heartbeat away from john mccain you
know keeling over from being president
of the united states it wasn't like
sarah palin was very close to becoming
president of the united states when you
think about it man well i mean she reads
all the papers all of them you know yeah
just all of them
all
i mean you name it i read it just name
it and i'll say that i read it you know
what's crazy about sarah palin
uh in in the pop culture of politics and
this professional wrestling style uh uh
view of politics that a lot of people
have
is we have we now have like a whole
a whole crew of sarah palin's in
congress with like lauren beaubert and
margaret
dude seriously they they all they
started like wearing glasses and fixing
the hair and doing the b bippity bops on
stage and i'm like holy [ __ ]
we had one sarah palin and now we've got
a dozen of them like they're all there
and they hold off as sarah palin you
know she she lost and she quit being
governor because it was too much but
these people are in
charge of [ __ ] they're in charge of
stuff i know it's crazy matt gates is
still on committee and there was a venmo
transaction you know talking about sex
trafficking
he's still on committee you know
and i said this week you know how bad of
a week is governor santez having when
the second most hated guy in florida is
matt gates you know that's that shows
you where florida's at you know that's
pretty shitty and you know it it does it
does tell you about the state of our
politics too because we're watching
andrew cuomo which um
we're recording this episode so so this
isn't this is uh stream live but we are
a few days ahead of when it's going to
be stream but today we're watching
andrew cuomo's administration just
completely blow up uh is basically his
top executive is resign um i i don't
know how long he can sustain not
resigning at this point because there's
going to be a forced impeachment it
looks like now for the scumbag he is and
and you know that that's that's the
problem with our body politics is is
only one party is held accountable for
all these misdeeds we have another party
that
and it's and i don't think it's because
of trump but trump showed the way to not
be held accountable like he gave the
model just deny it deny it deny it
[ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] we're just gonna
move on
and and
and say it's not true even though
there's clear evidence that there is
credible allegations and andrew cuomo
took that stance several weeks ago now
he's boxed in a corner here because the
democratic party is in the republican
party too is going to hold him
accountable so he's got it from both
sides whereas trump only got it from one
side only got it from the accountability
was only coming from one side the other
side was like no well i mean you still
have jim jordan as a congressman right
jim i don't report sex crimes jordan is
is a congressman who has the past who
hasn't passed a bill in 12 years as a
congressman well i mean i guess
i i use the word congressman with jim
jordan very lightly very lightly i mean
he is elected but
a congressman is is uh is insulting
other congress people so
what you mentioned about him is so true
though tony like
what what trump has done most lasting
damage that he's done to this country is
that he's normalized chaos
you know he's made it normal and the
crazy thing is and what's really scary
about 2022 and why nolan and i are like
panicking and hitting hitting things
with a little more of a sense of urgency
is you think things are bad now with
margie taylor greene look at the next
you know election cycle and we have 10
or 15 of these q anon nut bags in
congress you won't be able to get
anything finished right wait till wait
till we have four dozen sarah palin's
and congress again i'm telling you
because that's where it's that's where
it's headed and and and you know i i
appreciate you and you and noel doing
all the work that you're doing over
there uh because
the one thing uh that i think
can can put chinks in armor is when you
tell like you said truth to power and i
know noel has a lot of experience uh not
just inside the entertainment industry
but inside that trump uh universe and
the people that were around him and
created this this fake facade of this
great businessman
and and he did he played a businessman
on tv i mean
the dude inherited a half a billion
dollars um and anyone who knows anything
about money knows that he should be able
to turn it into about 30 30 billion
in the time that he's had it but he's he
hasn't um so he is he is a it is all
fraud it's all [ __ ] he's not a great
business person he's a horrible [ __ ]
buffoon he has no clue what he's doing
that's why he just throws money at any
problem that comes along because that's
what he's always done because it's all
about solving the next problem solving
the next problem it's never about you
know profits or anything like that it's
always about solving the next problem
what's my problem now and how do i solve
it with money right and where do i get
it who do i grifted off of who do i
steal it from who do i not pay the bill
to get the money that i need to solve my
personal problem over here that you know
people are gonna catch on to me not
being rich because i think that's the
tax return thing that he doesn't want
people to see is he doesn't want people
to actually know that it was all
[ __ ] that he's he's he's a [ __ ]
fraud so but i appreciate the work that
you and noah doing in your podcast tell
us again when it's released tell us what
it is where you can find it tell us uh
the null castler podcast uh new episodes
are released uh on mondays at noon um
most of the content right now is gonna
be talking about trump and the chaos
agent that he is to our country um
and you know talking about global
warming things are going to impact us
all you know nola and i both are kind of
holistic problem solvers when it comes
to our society and then my podcast jbk
on air just kind of a creative vessel um
that you guys can check out um a lot of
my friends are interviewed everything
from athletes to media professionals so
give it give it a listen
so go follow jimmy on social media the
tweets and the instagrams
jbk on air jimmy kennedy thanks for
joining me buddy i really do appreciate
it keep up your work over there on your
podcast and knowles podcast uh jimmy
kinney the executive producer of the
noel castler podcast thanks for joining
me today buddy
uh we'll have you back my pleasure all
right we'll see it we'll see you have a
good one
oh
what an episode
what an episode gave us an insight into
mike pence personal stories which no one
is surprised that this guy is who he is
or what he was and
who he pretends to be no one's surprised
by this
um yeah you know that that's the whole
fraud of trump and anyone around trump
is that you have to pretend to be a
certain way and it has to be a certain
a certain fraud to make sure that
everyone thinks that's that's the trump
cards the trump cards is a fraud
jesus
there's a nazi eagle on it
it's a nazi
german nazi eagle it's it's the [ __ ]
russian colors
what the and it's a trump card that you
pay 50 for for what
for what so it burns a hole in your
wallet i don't know where what does it
afford you what does it get you what do
you get
do you do you get to go to
trump rallies i i don't understand what
the [ __ ] the trump card is the official
membership card is for what's the
membership to that you're a you're
officially a member of the grifton cult
i don't know
and that in that in itself is
just a summation of trump and everything
around him is the 50 for a trump
membership card
well i want to thank jimmy again for
joining us
again this is a special guest episode
we're going to air this at a special
time now my live show is on wednesday
it's three o'clock central four o'clock
eastern
but we're gonna find a time to release
more and more of these guest episodes
i'm gonna try to get more guests on so
if you guys want to hear from somebody
out there
and on the interwebs rather it be on
twitter or tick tock let me know let
them know
they can come on the show we can hash
this out uh we can try to fix this
country we'll see how it works out in
the meantime though in the meantime [ __ ]
them
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries
i think we've made that perfectly clear
we hope you enjoyed the show and we'll
be back soon in the meantime follow tony
on social media at the tony michaels and
until next time raise a fist and repeat
after me
[Music]
[ __ ]